y un panel de expertos de la oms está
reunido hoy en ginebra para examinar los
datos sobre el uso de la vacuna de
astrazéneca lo mismo hace la ema existe
una causalidad entre la vacuna y los
efectos de trombosis
en estos momentos no se puede establecer
una relación causal se está examinando
la evidencia tanto el panel en ginebra-
de lado ms como el de la agencia europea
del medicamento resolverán si hay en
efecto una relación causal y eso ya nos
llevará a una decisión definitiva más
allá de las decisiones cautelares
prudenciales que se han tomado
hemos visto varios países europeos que
anunciaron que dejan de vacunar con
astrazéneca pero a diferencia en reino
unido país al que pertenece la empresa
junto con suecia siguen utilizándola y
no reportan ninguna afectación cómo
explicar esto podrían moverse algunos
intereses en esta decisión
siempre existe la posibilidad de que hay
un interés de guerra comercial un
interés geopolítico pero yo creo que lo
que tenemos que hacer es ajustarnos a la
evidencia científica de si hay o no
efectos secundarios que puedan ser
atribuibles a la vacuna hasta el momento
se trata de un efecto muy infrecuente en
el caso de españa- por ejemplo donde
vivo yo ha sido un caso de trombosis en
800 mil vacunas estamos hablando de una
frecuencia de un evento que puede
también darse no asociado a la vacuna y
que puede estar ligado a alguna
condición preexistente o al uso de algún
medicamento previo o algunas
características de susceptibilidad
individual pero no debemos interpretarlo
como que la vacuna es insegura ni
debemos de tener una noción de que hay
que llamarse a extrañeza o sea
establecer una alarma ante la vacuna de
este aceite bueno y es que estamos en
emergencia mundial
nos urge la vacunación así que le
pregunto qué efectos puede tener en la
toma de estas medidas drásticas de parar
las inoculaciones con astrazéneca en los
procesos de campañas de inmunización
bueno para los países europeos que han
detenido a la vacunación evidentemente
esto va a significar reducir la
velocidad a la que van avanzando en sus
programas de vacunación en estos
momentos los países están vacunando
contra en europa con tres vacunas facer
modernas y astrazéneca se acaba de
aprobar la de johnson y johnson y
entrará en vigor muy pronto mientras más
dispongamos de distintas vacunas
eficaces y seguras más rápido podremos
avanzar en la vacunación pero por
supuesto detenerse 15 días aunque sea
cautelarmente por un principio de
prudencia bueno disminuye la intensidad
a la que se produce esta vacuna estos
son países que estaban vacunando con
astrazéneca a personas menores de 55
años ahí es en donde se ha detenido pero
yo considero que tendremos una evidencia
muy clara en breve que permitirá
reanudar la vacunación si no hay ninguna
prueba de que hay algún efecto causal de
la vacuna con la trombosis